في المزيد من التفاصيل نعود الى الزميله
نجوان سمري مراسله الجزيره من القدس
ونحاول ان نستذكر معك تطور المشهد حتى هذه
اللحظه اليك الكلمه
نعم بالفعل ما زال الوضع في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك في غايه من التوتر وقد بدا ذلك
مباشره بعد انتهاء صلاه التراويح هذا
اليوم ومثل كل يوم اخر شهر رمضان المبارك
قوات الاحتلال المسجد وتبدا بتفريغ المسجد
من كافه المصلين والمعتك
صدر عنها منذ البدء هذا الشهر الفضيل بعدم
السماح بالاعتكاف داخل المسجد الاقصى
المبارك والبقاء في المساجد والمرافق بين
صلاه التراويح وصلاه الفجر
وقالت بانها قد تسمح بذلك فقط في الايام
العشر الاواخر وبالتالي
بدء هذا الشهر بدات قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
المسجد الاقصى المبارك ليليا بعد انتهاء
صلاه التراويح
لتفريغ
المسجد واخراج كافه المصلين من داخله وقد
شهدنا حاله من التوتر في عده ايام في
الايام الماضيه السابقه جزاء هذا الاعتداء
من قبل قوات الاحتلال لكن هذه الليله كان
الاعتداء الاكبر عمليا ذلك لان
مجموعه من المعتطفين والمصلين رفضوا
الخروج من المسجد الاقصى المبارك تح ديدا
من المسجد القبله القبلي وقاموا باغلاق
الابواب من الداخل
داخل المسجد الاقصى وارادوا ان يعتكفوا
لمواصله العباده
طيله الليل حتى صلاه
الشرطه الاسرائيليه شرطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اعتلت مباشره
المسجد القبلي
واصبح المسجد قبل وبدات بتكسير النواذ
وهذا المشهد يتكرر تكون مره عمليا
لتقوم من خلال النوافذ باطلاق قنابل الغاز
والصوت وايضا بعض جهود العيان افادون من
داخل المسجد القبلي بانه ثم ايضا اطلاق
الاعذيه المطاطيه او الرصاص المعدني
المغلف بالمطاط تجاه المعتكفين بالعاده
تكون شرطه الاحتلال بذلك لاحداث اصابات في
صفوف المعتكبين ما قد يستدعي طلبهم
للمساعده الطبيه ودخول الاسعاف وبالتالي
تتفتح الابواب لكن هذا لم يحدث وما حدث هو
ان قوات الاحتلال قامت باقتحام العياده
الطبيه الملاصقه لجامع عمر
وهو ايضا من قبل ومن هناك
اين مشاهد قاسيه جدا كيف قامت القوات
بالاعتداء بالضرب المبرح على
المعتكبين وقد صدر بيان قبل قليل عن شرطه
الاحتلال قالوا بانهم قاموا
عشرات الشبان والمعتكفين من داخل المسجد
الاقصاء المبارك